in broad daylight
a teenager is about to be shot
the protesters circled ismia
she's taking cover with her sister and
other protesters
in myanmar's capital when you hear a
crack
we've stopped the tape but immediately
she collapses
and is dragged away
forever
this is the scene in the lead up to the
shooting
protesters versus water cannon and
armed police the hole in mia's helmet
shows the round went into the back of
her head
doctors say the brain damage is
extensive she's been in intensive care
since tuesday
february 9th the day of the shooting was
the most
violent so far
as well as water cannon live rounds were
being used by the authorities
the military says it opened fire at
around 12
30 in response to violence by
demonstrators
photos from the scene show at least one
officer
with a sub machine gun this is not a
weapon
that fires rubber bullets this is not a
weapon that fires less lethal weapons
this is a weapon that fires
bullets which are you know designed to
kill today is mia's 20th birthday
it's unclear if she'll ever wake up
a face they can rally behind the
shooting of an
unarmed teenager has only fueled the
anger on the streets
and cemented the hatred of the military
behind the coup
siobhan robbins sky news